good afternoon we are here with
bachor World scholar on Islam in the
west and historian we were here together
where I called to the pope she's my Pope
anyway back in 2007 where we discussed
Islam in the west today I'd like to talk
about something else that you have been
working on uh the book that you that's
in Italian and it's coming out in
English towards the universal caliphate
I think the the Ambassador John Bolton
is writing the forward yes he promised
one I am very grateful to him and um
what we'd like to talk about today is
how the left How the West is enabling uh
the uh encroaching or should say the
Galloping islamization of the West okay
the first question I have for you is how
are how are Western authorities
advancing the uh islamization uh of the
West the encroaching Sharia I can only
speak about Europe because in America
the situation is quite different but in
Europe there has been
since uh
1970s when there was a strong
development of Palestinian terrorism
there have been um Arrangements
dialogue
engagement between the the European
government and the countries of the Arab
League
so this um type of um uh dialogue and um
complacent um complacent
um
uh uh relationships yes where the the
European countries accepted the request
of the Arab Le
countries um has uh developed have
spread in Europe um lots of
Muslim uh cultural
centers and also has encouraged Muslim
immigration which is uh of course uh
promoting and bringing the development
of mosques because you cannot have a big
population without the mosque if you if
you have you agree to have an important
popul immigrant population you have to
give them their religious rights right
and this means also the uh Arabic uh
lessons Arabic uh Arab institutions and
so on and so on so we could have seen
since the uh 70s until now a
progression of an islamization and
arabization of the West without the
European European populations being
aware of it and
especially that this
Arrangement uh were organized at the
level of the uh Cultural Center the
university the media and so on the the
uh dialogues between Western European
University and uh Arab one all those
arrangements have been done without the
knowledge of the
populations so one of the aspects
therefore of the islamization of Europe
is immigration of course demographic
immigration which brings Islamic culture
the other element is
multiculturalism the European government
have promoted
multiculturalism um without the having
this important problem discussed with
the the European
population and another element another U
important factor is uh
globalization globalization means that
uh
The Sovereign countries lose their own
sovereignty on many aspects and accept
Global governance which come from the e
from the EU the United Nation from the
United Nations so this we we see for
instance that the the United Nation
regulations are more and
more uh imposing them themselves and um
uh
ruling the uh the countries uh the
Western count Western European countries
and I found this a danger because the
OIC the organization of Islamic
country is uh having uh a always a
increasing
influence on um on the United Nations
and on the United Nation
rulings and therefore uh I think that it
is a a danger for
democracy because the European people
are losing the control they have on
their own
politics because they cannot control
they cannot decide what is going on in
the United Nation and their own in
Democratic
institutions are weakened by the
development of the United Nation
uh
domination and rules so the populations
don't know what is happening they have
lost the control of their own policy and
their own future in within the movement
of globalization yes now I did a series
of articles on the euromid partnership
Now isn't the Euro euromed partnership a
continuation of this policy where basic
you're opening up the floodgates to
Africa freedom of movement I don't I
don't expect Europeans will be going
there I expect Africans will be coming
into Europe without paperwork I mean
it's opening up the flood gates to
immigration yes of course this is this
was the first the beginning of the the
the globalization if you want process it
was um it was restricted to
the Mediterranean region it was Europe
and the Arab Mediterranean countries
right so this has create a a
syncretic
hidiz of um uh the judeo-christian
culture and the Islamic culture we see
more and more that in the EUR in Europe
a kind of ization Islamic
ization of the uh Western culture so
much so that the European Union
renounce uh to what is the pillar of its
uh identity it is the judeo-christian
identity and it refused to recognize it
it be in order to accommodate Muslim
immigrations Muslim immigrants in Europe
so you can say that there is in fact
this
Mediterranean uh
Mediterranean
Society um where uh there is a
symbiosis but the symbiosis more is more
in the islamization of Europe than in
the
westernization of the Islamic countries
because we see that the OIC the
organization of the Islamic country is
now uh
uh working in order to um root the
Islamic
world in the values and tradition of the
Quran and the Sunnah so to make it even
more Islamic it is not going toward us
toward
westernization but the the the develop
the new development
of the future of the Islamic world will
be toward more Islam and more
radicalization while the OIC request
from the Western countries and Europe
that it becomes
Multicultural so in fact it is asking
from us what they refuse to do in the
Islamic
countries and America joining the
alliance of civilizations which to my
understanding is something of a proxy to
the OIC the organization of Islamic
conference countries um is I start as
very disturbing news I was wondering if
you could give us your take on America
joining the alliance of
civilizations yes well the alliance of
civilization is a very huge
organization which is as you say proxy
of the
OIC it's a main concern as it stated in
its report written in
2006 is to bring together uh the Western
World with
Islam this is its main one of its main
uh Focus so how to do it well it promote
the uh projects of the I we know the
what the OIC is requesting from the from
the Western World and um it's uh the the
alliance of civilization it's the the
mouth of the
OIC now on the other hand of course it
is
important that especially in the uh age
of U nuclear weapons that we avoid uh
Wars and uh and conflict because they
will be very
dangerous however we have to uh
recognize that we are now engaged into a
conflict which is a jihadist
conflict and uh the West must get out of
its culture of the
and lies and acknowledge that terrorism
is in fact a war a type of war and it
has to ask the OIC the organization of
the Islamic countries which is an
umbrella Organization for the 56 Muslim
countries and which yeld an enormous
power so it has to the man to request
from this
organization that it uh it has to make
also some steps in the direction of the
West it is not only the West that has to
uh renounce to many of its uh uh
principles and of its own identity in
order to meet uh uh uh Islam but it has
to be a
a a a a
CA a Coss Direction process that both
must go toward one another otherwise if
only the West is doing all the efforts
the West will become already a Dei a Dei
continent a Dei Society a Dei culture
yeah and just for people that are not
familiar with the term dii because you
are the leading expert on it you coin
the term dimude yes that's and Arabia
too that's that was yours uh just for
the people explain dimude explain the
dimma just so that they understand what
it means well um the deud is the
civilization that was developed by the
population the non-muslim
populations that were um conquered by
Jihad because Jihad is not just any War
Jihad has an ideology and has its ruling
it its um
jurisdiction and this uh jurisdiction
imposed on those population a total
subjection to the Islamic rulers and
also impose some uh some
rules uh to which the non-muslim must uh
must abide
and must apply and among those rules it
is the uh the fact and the
prohibition uh or to criticize Islam so
if uh you cannot criticize only one
religion this is
absolutely um contrary to our principles
in the west because everything can be
criticized and especially that Islam is
together a religion a law and a politics
so if you cannot criticize the politics
of Islam and that Islam wants to
islamize you so this means that you are
neutralized you cannot defend yourself
NE exactly so and this is in fact uh a
tendency that we can see in the OIC with
the policy of uh
denouncing uh so much islamophobia in
the west the policy of the of accusation
of
islamophobia is in a way uh also um a
mean to neutralize a a political
political mean to neutralize our defense
and we have to be aware of that yes and
people are not aware of it in the media
is aligned with the terror Force because
it's part of the ausc people it's very
confusing to people yes it is very
confusing because first of all the
Western world and I must say also many
Muslims do not not know the the Muslim
shakia the Muslim jurisdiction they
don't understand that this this rule
they don't understand what is the
blasphemy law for instance so what are
the Sharia laws they don't understand so
for them all this is
a something they cannot fight against
because they don't understand what it is
but also many
Muslims uh don't know that and for them
uh they can consider that the reaction
of the West to uh the adoption of
certain Muslim custom can be
islamophobic because they don't know the
background of of this history they don't
know the history of jihad for instance
right so because the uh Islamic view of
History the Islamic interpretation of
history is only according to Sharia and
this means that Islamic history is
perfect it's and there was nothing wrong
Jihad has nothing wrong this is why we
canot criticized Jihad because
everything is perfect so we have a a a a
a um a
conflict an argument even on Words yes
what is Jihad what is
Terrorism um we canot even say the
criticize Jihad now for instance we also
cannot
criticize Islamic Justice we have to say
we have to know that Islamic Justice is
uh the Justice according to
Sharia but as we cannot abide to this
interpretation of Justice because it
means Shia promote the cutting of the
Lambs uh the the also crucifixion in
case of
uh uh APO apostasy and many other
aspects so this is not Justice for us we
have another definition of justice
justice is equality of men and women it
is uh equality of all human beings it is
based on the Ten Commandments it is
based on the enlightenment it is based
on a lot of other principles with we
which are not uh based on Sharia so when
we speak about Justice even this
word is has different meaning yeah when
we speak of Peace it is different it has
different meaning peace in Islam is
peace according to
Sharia peace for us is contrary to what
it is mean what it means in the
Sharia now you saw that the counter
Terror ISM advisor to President Obama
said that Jihad was a legitimate Tenant
of Islam isn't this very dangerous isn't
this more
accusation yes of course this is because
this uh is
according with the Islamic um vision of
its own history Jihad because it is a
war
to expand the religion of Islam um in
the world is a just uh a perfect and
just
activity because it is done according to
the it is uh done according to the uh
Quran uh request and um uh commment so
it cannot be wrong because everything
which is quranic is perfect because it
come straight from Allah you cannot
criticize so Jihad is according to the
to
Muhammad activities and
commandment so if us the Western World
which has been have been for 13th
century the victims of jihad which is a
very barbarous and violent war and we
cannot criticize this war and we say it
is it is good so then it is
self-defeating
yes now what do you what do you think of
the political significance of the
Islamic
delegitimization of Judaism and
Christianity well I think that this of
course goes with the Islamic belief that
consided that uh Jews and Christians
have falsified
the only religion which is which is
Islam right and which consider that the
Hebrew history and the Hebrew Prophet
were Muslim prophets including Jesus
that Jesus was a Muslim Prophet yeah
they ran that on the bus ads yeah yes
yes so they um so in this case uh if the
Bible is a a a the history of Muslim uh
before the
of Muhammad yeah if we have falsified in
our Bible first and second
testament the the real Message of Islam
that was preached by the Hebrew prophet
and by Jesus then we have we have
falsified the real religion and
therefore are um our historical uh
conception uh on
Israel uh and Christianity are all false
because the biblical story is not a
Jewish history it is a Muslim history
according to the Islamic view right so
this is why Israel has no legitimate
right in its own country so we see here
that Christian Christian cannot if they
are Christian they cannot accept
that uh Israel has no uh
legitimate uh
national uh root in the land of the
Bible because the Christian have
accepted the first testament it is part
of them their own uh religious identity
yes so if they renounced that and if
they accept that uh Jesus was Muslim
Prophet who preach Islam they renounce
therefore to the to Jesus the Hebrew
Jesus the Jewish Jesus they renounce to
in fact their own their whole
Christianity so we have here a very
important religious
conflict which we haven't yet discussed
with the Muslim world and until they
recognize the legitimacy of our own
religious history and
identity and they renounced to
islamized uh our history and ass our
history I don't see how we can get
together we cannot have a an agreement
another problem is that the Muslim says
that all children are born Muslims yeah
therefore they see us as
apostate and because we are born Muslim
you see in
principle so there are all those aspects
that the uh usually the Western public
do not uh do not acknowledge do not know
so so that the this conflict which is
very complicated because it has
theological political legal aspects
historical as aspect is not understood
but how are you going to get them to
recognize the legitimacy of Judaism and
Christianity when their whole religion
is based on falsifying it it's like when
I discuss expunging the Quran of its
violent texts uh the problem that I see
and you are the world's leading
historian on Islamic anti-Semitism it's
very much a part of the doctrine is it
not can you discuss Islamic
anti-Semitism with us for just a bit yes
well it is uh it it started of course
with the problem of Muhammad because
Muhammad prophet Muhammad wanted to um
to Islam islamized the Jews first he
believed that he was bringing a message
in Conformity with that of Judaism and
he thought the same with Christianity
that they would be accepted by the
Christians too but then in Medina there
was the a a a big Jewish community and
the they of course they uh they didn't
accept his ideas his ideas and he
because also he didn't know much about
about the Bible and therefore um there
was
a
um conflict and Muhammad uh got rid of
the the Jews There It Is Well known U
one of the tribe they he expelled them
um there another tribe he ex expel and
took all their
belongings and the third one was um was
massacred and the Kisa and uh also the
the children and women were taking
taking
slavery but um uh then he got continue
his work against the Jews who lived in
the other oazis in Arabia and he uh and
then there was a Contin continual
conflict because Muhammad thought he was
bringing the real Bible that the Quran
was the real Bible you see and therefore
and we still have this conflict now yeah
that the this is why the the Muslim says
that Bible is a falsified version of the
Quran of Islam you see so
um there was there is in his in his
conflict with the Jews in Arabia uh and
in his war against the Jews uh of course
he developed um verses versus were uh
revealed uh which um uh direct him to
Wag war against the Jews and
anti-Semitism or judeophobia
rather in this case judeophobia
um developed very strongly uh from the
war of Muhammad against the Jews there
and then it was it became it was taken
through the biography of the prophet
phets with of the Prophet who was were
published two centuries later and in the
Hadi which are the uh spe the Sacred
Scriptures of uh of Islam and it was
there given an
Institutional and legal form the the the
states of the Jews and the
Christians and uh therefore
uh this since they are fored sacred so
we have a whole body of sacred Islamic
ruling which are extremely judeophobia
are called as Idol idolators pag
idolators right yes yes or
associationist this is the uh people who
associate other gods to one God so in
fact and also because of the war that
developed later with the with the
Christians against the Christians so the
uh the uh the the the history Islamic
history and uh legal institutions and
rulings have a whole body of anti-jewish
anti-christian also anti-
Pagan um important uh how you say
baggage and this absolutely if we want
the Peace of
civilization this must be
examined now the how would you say that
the US now along with the EU is a
advancing Islam in the
west um well because this is in the Pro
this
is the root in the in
the uh ideology of
refusing War the EU was built on the
refusal of any war in the nuclear age so
it has adopted an accom
accommodating and engagement policy with
the Muslim World in order to avoid
conflict but also there are also other
reasons which are based on economic
needs since the Islamic
world is has an enormous Reser of uh
energy energy right uh uh
so economic
reasons um and the desire to have good
relation with the Muslim world and the
renouncement of One's Own identity which
is very strongly developed in Europe but
not in America but this maybe will come
because the European want because in
Europe we had a very strong
Nazi uh leftish
communist uh uh
tendency which was anti-european and
anti-religious so because of this
historical
baggage um Europe wanted didn't mind to
renounce to its own identity especially
if it was judao Christian identity which
it rejected and it went into the uh
agreement with the Islamic world now we
see with this Obama administration the
leftist ad Administration the Democratic
one we see the same vision it is an
ideology it is the desire to create a
world a peaceful world where there won't
be any boundary religious boundary
um National B boundaries everyone will
be together the brother and sister but I
think that um hell is paved with good
intention and that um uh this is a um it
is not a very
realistic uh situation Vision we have to
see that we we have enemies and we have
to know why there are enemies and we
have to deal with enemies if we want
peace we have to deal with enemies we
cannot pretend that we have no
enemies so what should the Western
governments what should the US what
should Europe be doing well I think I
speak now about Europe I think what we
see in Europe is a the M of a a
conscious of this all those problems now
BEC aware of it yes on the grassroot the
people yeah the people yes like yes like
for those who support G Builders yes and
other like that also so people are
bringing uh pressure on their
government to force them to listen to
them because after afterward after all
those governments were are elected in
order to take care and protect the wish
of the their citizen citizens yes not to
make dealing with Arab countries and to
arrange for a huge Muslim immigration so
they are now forcing the government to
take their respons responsibilities and
if they are
incompetent because the the leaders of
the governments are there to serve and
this is very strongly developed in
America they are there to serve the
people not to serve their pocket or
their own ambition so there is much more
demands now which are done on the
leaders and they have to listen to their
own people now how to do ask the
European people and this is also in the
very much now
discussed uh we have to know what is our
identity it is based on what what are
the pillars of our identity and we have
to know what are the principles on which
we will not uh discuss we will not
abandon the pr principles the Democratic
principle the principles of our
Democratic freedom of our rights we have
to to know what are their based and what
we are ready to fight for and I think
that all this in is being discussed now
and uh everywhere in Europe in different
places but when you have uh the signing
of the Lisbon treaty the country which
didn't want to do it
Czechoslovakia but when Ireland fell
which was surprising because they had
just voted the prior June against it
doesn't that somewhat
Vanquish uh National sovereignty of
course but this has even woken up more
the European people the Lisbon treaty
the Lisbon treaty because they realized
how the leaders are do
policy behind their back and without the
approval of their own uh citizens so
there are many people who reject the
Lisbon treaty many people who reject
reject the EU the European Union they
want of course what the um the
unification the integration of the
different countries of Europe is has
very positive aspect it's a very great
things but the there are discussion
about the what is the EU it is a super
National body that has
confiscated uh the national uh
sovereignty of the people yeah and which
is uh engaging into globalization in a
big way and in a way that
the citizen cannot control they lose the
control of their own future and their
own Society so all those elements are
being discussed now and all this with a
a huge Muslim population in Europe which
is linked with the OIC right which is
acting uh uh in the contrary way to what
the citizens want so the SI situation is
becoming very conflictual in Europe now
you don't have in America this situation
because you are one country you speak
one language it is different no we're
experiencing something different I mean
my book is coming out in July the post
American presidency and the Obama
administrations were on America and
really a basic uh tenant of the book is
how Obama is abandoning American
sovereignty
uh relinquishing it to international law
we're seeing that increasingly which we
find very very troubling um and he seems
to not give a wit about the tea parties
I mean I know that they are smeared uh
in in the media as a millions of racists
which we know this is what they do to us
they call us bigots is racist
islamophobe and so on and so forth um
but how do you see how do you see it
playing out in America because he's very
islamophilia you see this yes of course
he said it he said a change he want a
change in policy yes and he want to
engage the Muslim world so he wants to
go with them toward them to please them
yes so it is clear that his policy will
be on this Bas yes so uh what I see it
is that um uh of course with
globalization with um which is the
engagement with the Muslim World which
is a process within the
globalization so this uh this of course
uh will lead America to relinquish some
of its sovereignty it is for the
American to decide where they want to
go what they want to to keep how how
they will manage within globalization it
is very a very complicated it's a very
problem because we are going to a new
world now especially with the change
excuse
me with the exchange with the um big
Immigration Movement yeah with um also
the uh communication facilities of
communication um
so toward what we are going we are
losing the past the secure past and we
have to build the future but with what
and how and um it is a very
destructured world that we have now at
least in the west because I don't think
China has change the Muslim world in the
on the contrary is building itself yeah
this is why I called it the CATE because
the Muslim world now is getting a very
strong organization which is the
organization of the Islamic confer which
has many uh instrument internal
instrument and which um uh it has its
own uh Court of human right according to
Sharia it's own International tribunal
according to Sharia also and several
other bodies and it as it had said in
several of its statement it want the OIC
want to build the universal um this is
the Muslim worldwide worldwide yes on
rooting it in the Quran and the Sunnah
so it is it is not like us which are
destructured we don't know where is our
identity we
are full of guilt because of this
because of that they have a very strong
position and there are uh according to
their uh text they want to create a a
western Islam which is linked to the
universal um and will a Europe Western
Islam linked to the universal um and
which will be uh organized and
coordinate through
uh Muslim
schools um Muslim teaching uh and uh
Muslim centers and the media also mus
media all that coordinated throughout
the West W world so we shall see this
emergence of an a western Islam which is
will be very strongly rooted in its uh
uh original uh values the Quran and the
sunna within a Western World which is uh
corroding which is a totally decaying
Decay and which is even doesn't
reproduce itself yeah it is totally
doesn't the youth don't get married
don't have children so
demographically we don't have a future
if we don't reproduce ourselves yes
apart from the
problem that we have the cultural
problems and the problem of our own
identity so this is in addition to the
books which I'm going to list on the
website her books which is seminal work
works this is what you cover in your
latest book on the universal caliphate
is this what you discussed yes yes
exactly that what I am discussing also
is uh that with
globalization the uh Democratic process
of government of each country are
replaced by transnational
networks like the in Europe the analin
foundation
or on a worldwide scale the alliance of
civilizations the alliance of
civilization is a
gigantic Network that collaborate with
several countries on different level
which are political historical um
military religious on all levels and
which impact on the G governments of the
countries through uh through this
networks so in fact Theocratic process
are replaced Now by uh the uh work of
transnational networks like for the UN
the UN is a gigantic network if the UN
give a ruling well it it
superseded the rule the rules the laws
of the country of different countries
and the and it has to be accepted it has
to be uh follow up you see so we are now
I don't know about America but in Europe
we are now determined our policy is
determined and is obey to networks
networks are by
Essence um uh not not individuals there
are lots of people who are working in
networks it's Collective Collective so
you don't know they opak you don't know
whom to whom you have you if you are not
happy of something you cannot go to a
person and and complain so it is a
inhuman
Anonymous uh organization Kafkaesque
organization which is going to rule the
world and all this because of the OIC
organization and strengths all these
networks are strongly influenced by the
OIC so the OIC is in fating in fact
getting more and more power into these
networks that
control our life but the idea of America
probably the most noble experiment in
human history the most moral government
it was based on individual rights this
is in our DNA I mean no matter how
different we may all be the basic idea
of individual rights um uh the opposite
of collectivism the opposite of statism
I mean Americans are going to feel this
and you see Americans are not while they
may have been because everything was so
good and so easy uh Americans are not
passive I don't know that you'll be able
to just snatch away this idea that it
defines us I mean I don't know if
America will save the world but I I
don't know but I don't know that they'll
go quietly do you think they'll go
quietly I hope they will not because
this will mean because America is a very
great country it's a very really pillar
of Western
Civilization it it has got to the best
of of it also it has many dark aspects
in its own history but at least it
recognized it and this is very important
because every na Nation every people
every individual have a dark aspect in
their personality and in their history
what is important is to recognize it
right and to and to change it this is
fundamentally what's wrong in Islam that
you cannot no can you cannot criticized
so this is so America is a great nation
it has a tremendous potentiality it has
given a lot to the world and um of
course if America is going to follow
this the direction that Europe has taken
and it seems to yes well it is uh it
will be very very serious for our
civilization our principle our
values and
uh it will be a collapse of an enormous
magnitude but I must say that now in
Europe there is a a a movement
of I wouldn't say Revolt but resistant
movement against that so there is some
resistance at least it doesn't mean that
it will succeed right because it is very
difficult to go against what has been
done for so many um decades and
also to to organize a a political body
that will know how to deal with those
problems are very
complex on on the on the level of a
continent because it is not not in one
country it is in the whole of Europe so
it is on the level of a
continent and but
uh this has to be done if
Europe what Europe
represent uh and the West
represent want to survive otherwise it
will not survive it will not survive so
the first thing you know after 911 when
I I started this journey because before
911 I was cognizant of really nothing um
I came to see you at Columbia yeah and I
was so blown away by what your remarks
had revealed I had come up to you and I
said you know what do I do what should I
do and you said to me first learn
everything it was the best advice I ever
got and I guess that's what people have
to do first they really must they must
learn everything and not go to the usual
resources that they go to like the media
because the culture has been completely
corrupted yes it has been corrupted and
subverted yes by the Islamic version of
History which is not ours our version
but we're accepting it yes we because
our Authority our universities are
imposing it yes you see in uh in in
Islam you say the human rights
declaration Islam says that the research
of knowledge is very it as long as it is
done according to Sharia so according to
Sharia mean that you cannot
criticize um the Quran you cannot
criticize Islamic history you can cannot
criticize any
anything really religious it is a
religious version of
uh of um history which is not compatible
with our version of History which is
based on
critique and of
a CRI analysis and examination of facts
yeah no there's no facts no no if you
have to say that everything is perfect
in Islam so you don't really have to and
then the the historical
demonstration must be according to this
conclusion that everything is perfect in
in Islam
so already you have the demonstration
the the
result any idea when your book is going
to be
out well it will be out in French uh in
October and then in uh in
America um I am looking for uh the
translation is not yet uh finished yes I
have to work a little bit on it so
hopefully you'll come back and we'll
talk again when it's out in English
we wanted to be a
besteller with Pamela Geller at shrugs
thank you very much thank
you